first in saw its first night of relative
calm in quite some time last night I
know you've spoken to a lot of people
there on the ground do they feel as
though racism is something that's just
inherent in the culture of that town yes
that's something I've been hearing all
through the week that I've been here
people saying that Michaels Michael
Brown step was just a tipping point it
was something that sort of the straw
that broke the camel's back people say
they have been stopped by police they
believe they have been basically given
harassment by police and there is
different people here in Ferguson and
people say that they just you know they
just couldn't take it anymore after
Michael Brown was killed you know you
heard so let's say that Peter that
people are saying that they feel as
though they have been singled out they
have been harassed in part because of
just the color of their skin you've
looked into this there's a lot of
research that suggests the police are in
fact doing exactly that well the art
City defenders report that I mentioned
was prepared earlier this year before
before Ferguson made the headlines and
it it found that blacks are stopped
disproportionately for traffic
violations disproportionate to their
race secondly when they are stopped
they're twice as likely to be searched
as white drivers and when they are
searched there only two thirds is likely
for the police to find any contraband on
them but but then they go to court the
the whites who tend to be higher income
not always but can afford a lawyer they
managed to get a moving violation
knocked down to a non-moving violation
blacks come to court without a lawyer
and disproportionately end up getting a
moving violation which of course cause
some points on their license and they
also are more likely to pay a fine which
they cannot afford and they are more
likely to go to jail because they are
not it's like this spiral downward that
that is taking on a momentum all on its
own right so you you go to these courts
in Ferguson it's a ton of only twenty
one thousand but courts are a big part
of its operation and they'll be
all black defendants so there is nothing
in there that says they are specifically
targeting blacks blacks have lower
income and they tend to they tend to
suffer far more from this behavior and
this is so so the art City defenders
report named three towns this is again
before august nine the report was
released after August ninth in Ferguson
was one of those three towns um you know
is there much talk about that report
there on the ground in Ferguson to lose
I think people are talking more just
about the contents not necessarily of
being aware of the report being out but
they definitely confirm what this report
has has found which is you know they say
that they go to court all the time and
is he a ton of black people who can who
can get fine and who probably don't have
a lawyer and they believe that another
place where the criminal justice system
in their lines discriminates against
them as well as the police officers who
initially stop them I here I have had a
lot on the streets of Ferguson and it
seems to be backed up in this report um
but this isn't necessarily just specific
to first and Peter well no it's not I
mean clearly we have a national
conversation we need to have about race
I think the story my cover story tries
to look at it both ways the degree to
which is a national problem I mean one
one way you can look at it is pew
research center did a poll of all
Americans and ask them about Ferguson
and one of the questions was do you
believe that this is an occasion for
having a national conversation about
race eighty percent of blacks thought so
forty-four percent of whites thoughts so
the acid do you think the Ferguson
Police have overreacted two-thirds of
blacks thought so one-third of whites
thought so so we're looking at things
with through very different lenses in
this country